[Music]
the batman was filled with moments of
dramatic character revelations and
brutal action but one scene in
particular that dealt with selena kyle's
past stands out it's time to talk about
that catwoman scene in the batman while
the movie is called the batman selena
kyle also known as catwoman plays a
vital role in the story bruce wayne
first runs into her in the iceberg
lounge as she works for oswald kabul
potts as a server batman notices
selena's reaction to seeing pictures of
a mystery woman exiting the club with
mayor don mitchell jr batman follows
selena and discovers that the woman is
actually selena's roommate but the first
time they truly meet is when selena
breaks into the mayor's house to
retrieve her roommate's passport and
from that point on they are entangled as
the story unravels more of selena's
backstory and motivations are revealed
this includes a crucial connection with
carmine falcone the mob boss who works
closely with cobblepot and frequency
iceberg lounge when the truth of
falcone's crimes come to light thanks to
the riddler both selena and bruce decide
to go after falcone come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
unfortunately selena is a bit more
serious about how she wants to punish
him and bruce doesn't agree but there's
nothing stopping selena from going after
what she wants this leads to a key scene
in the last third of the film that
features major action and devastating
revelations once selena learns that
falcone is behind the death of her
roommate she decides to kill him heading
to his club she dresses up and asks to
talk to him in private hiding a gun in
her bag but selena is interrupted right
as she reaches for the weapon batman is
unleashing his wrath in the very next
room bruce wants to stop selena from
committing murder but he also has his
own business with falcone by this point
alfred has confirmed that all signs
point to falcone ordering the murder of
his parents years earlier but bruce is
forced to face off against guards and
selena gets the chance to confront
palcone she plans on getting revenge for
her roommate's brutal death she also
wants answers about the revelation that
she's felt kony's daughter which
apparently he doesn't know until this
moment it's equally possible that he
simply doesn't care feeling like her
father abandoned her years earlier and
knowing all of the horrors falcone has
committed selena pulls the trigger and
misses this leads father and daughter to
battle head on out in the open while
selena is skilled falcone's ruthlessness
allows him to gain the upper hand during
the confrontation of the club between
falcone and selena she plays the audio
that reveals his direct role in her
roommate's death she was an innocent
woman who just happened to hear too much
falcone strangles her a detail that only
minutes later becomes even more
important selena also reminds falcone of
her mother maria kyle and her death
earlier in the batman selena tells bruce
that her mother was murdered when she
was very young likely by one of the
clients of the club while falcone first
seems to feel some semblance of
emotional connection to selena's
mother's name another horrific truth
comes out as falcone attacks his
daughter he manages to knock her to the
ground and push down on her neck
beginning to strangle her it's at that
point that falcone reveals that he
killed maria the same way if selena
hadn't managed to get away soon after
she would have met the same fate as her
mother and though audiences might root
for selena to take down falcone for good
she decides that justice will be better
served if he lives to suffer the
consequences of his villainy to bruce it
means that selena won't have to hold on
to the trauma that comes from taking
someone's life in the end while it's not
by her own hand selena does see her
father die that night with a face-off
with balcony behind her selena decides
to leave gotham city and start over
somewhere else something bruce probably
should do as well but we all know he
never will check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the batman are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you